PROFESSOR: I'm excited
about today's lecture
because there's so
many fun topics.
This is like many fun
things all in one lecture.
We're going to start with a
cool little problem, which
is about unfolding
and re-folding.
You could think
of them-- they're
kind of like hinged
dissections although they're
from between surfaces
of polyhedra.
You can also think of
them as common unfoldings.
So general idea is,
you have over here
in the left team you have
unfoldings-- polygons,
let's say.
Possible things that
could fold into polyhedra.
And we'll think convex again.
And when we were
thinking about unfolding,
we we're thinking about
going this direction.
When we were thinking
about folding,
we were thinking
about this direction.
But what if we do
both repeatedly?
So I start, say, with a cube.
And then I unfold it
and then I re-fold it.
That's sort of what the
metamorphosis of the cube
was about.
And then I unfold
that and I re-fold it,
and I unfold and I re-fold
and I unfold and re-fold.
This is a fun tour to take.
Is this space connected?
Can I get from any
polyhedral surface
to any other-- say, convex--
by unfolding and re-folding?
We have no idea.
So while each of
these operations
we know a fair amount about--
we know how to generally unfold
convex polyhedra,
we know how to find
all of the gluings of a polygon
into a polyhedron-- repeating
those processes,
we could explore
but actually no ones' every
tried that algorithmically.
It'd be fun to see what
crazy things you get.
But we have lots of examples
and partial progress
towards this question.
So here's the first example.
This appears in the book.
It's by Hirata from 2000.
He was one of the guys who
implemented a gluing algorithm.
And this is an unfolding--
a common unfolding--
of a cube-- ah, not quite--
and a regular tetrahedron.
So it's actually
a box not a cube.
One of the big open
questions in this area
is, can you find
a common unfolding
of a perfect cube and a regular
tetrahedron that's open?
Marty posed that
question I think
in 1998, in the good old days of
the beginning of folding stuff.
And this is almost an answer
but it's not quite a cube,
as a result.
You could see-- I think
it's pretty easy to see
how to fold it into a box just
with extending all the lines.
And the dotted lines
show how to fold
into a regular tetrahedron.
That's one example.
You can also fold-- this thing
makes both a regular octahedron
instead of a regular tetrahedron
and some kind of tetrahedra.
It's not regular.
We call it a tetramonohedron,
meaning each of the sides
are the same.
So it's just one type of side,
but there's four of them.
And I guess the red lines
are folding into that,
the green lines fold into
a regular tetrahedron.
I feel like I'm
getting forgetful.
I don't even remember where
this example comes from.
But it's in the book, it's
not attributed to anyone
so I assume Joe invented it.
But recently, like
just this year,
inspired a whole bunch of
examples by these guys.
I just saw the talk
last week in China--
that's where I was traveling,
it was a geometry conference.
And Horiyama and Uehara
talked about a bunch
of different common unfoldings.
This is, again, of
a regular octahedron
and a tetramonohedron.
But a different example.
But they kept going.
Said all right, let's do
all the platonic solids.
So this is a common unfolding
of a cube and a tetramonohedron.
Cube-- actually two of them.
You can see how it makes a cube.
That's obvious.
But the tetramonohedron
are the blue lines.
Then I have the octahedron,
we have the icosahedron.
I don't think they
have a dodecahedron yet
because all of these
approaches are actually
based on dissection
techniques where
you take a tiling of-- here
are equilateral triangles
for the icosahedron,
and you take
a tiling of some
triangle that's going
to make the tetramonohedron,
and you align them
so that things work out nicely.
And that's not
always well defined,
but it often leads
to good dissections,
often hinged dissections.
It's the way, for
example, you show
you can hinge
dissect a rectangle
into any other rectangle.
You take tilings of
different rectangles
and overlay them appropriately.
Here, same approach,
but with a dodecahedron,
regular pentagons
don't tile so it's
very hard to use that approach.
So this is as far
as they've gotten.
Here they've measured
the proportions
of the tetramonohedron
to give you an idea.
It's close to regular.
But again, open question,
can any two platonic solids--
do any two have a
common unfolding?
They proved in this paper,
if you restrict one of them
to be an edge unfolding
and the other one
can be a general unfolding
then it's not possible.
But if they're both general
unfoldings, who knows.
Here you see it's edge
unfolding for the icosahedron,
but general unfolding
for the other.
Cool.
But very recently,
this is, like,
hasn't even been released yet.
This is the premier
of the following,
I'll call it conjecture.
I think it's not yet
approved or explicitly-- it's
not certain that it's correct.
But the claim is this gray
shape, taken to the limit--
so this is the first
iteration of the fractal,
this is the second iteration
of the fractal-- in the limit,
will fold both to a regular
tetrahedron and a cube.
This would be an
amazing breakthrough.
Still, the conjecture
is that it is not
possible to go from
a regular tetrahedron
to a cube with a regular--
like a normal polygon
with a finite number of sides.
But with an infinite number of
sides, it seems to be possible.
Which is awesome.
This is-- I haven't
met this guy yet.
He's a professional puzzler
in Japan, Toshihiro Shirakawa.
So stay tuned for maybe a proof
of that theorem, that claim.
The next topic--
this started back
in '99, inspired
by this question.
We thought well,
what about boxes?
And this is a common unfolding
of two different size boxes
which is cool.
And it's generated in
a fairly intuitive way.
You start with an
unfolding of a box.
This makes a one
by one by three box
if you think about it
for a little while.
Just wrap around-- this
is like one top side, 1
by 3 rectangle and wrap around.
And then you-- you
draw the gluing-- here
I've labeled which edges
glue to which edges.
And for every letter,
like the two Gs
here, I could imagine adding a
triangle here and removing it
from here.
That will still fold to
the same thing, right?
So I get to choose
for each letter which
guy goes in, which guy goes out.
Then I get this shape as
a result of that process.
And if I do it right,
when I rotate 45 degrees,
I get a different orthogonal
unfolding of some other box.
So here, if I started
with a root 2 by root 2
by three root 2 box, I
get a 1 by 2 by 4 box.
So this is a common
unfolding of both.
I guess here is like the
center core of the 1 by 2 by 4
and you wrap around again.
Or this is probably center core.
So that's pretty cool.
This is an idea by Timothy Chan.
Of course, natural
question is, do I
need to do this rotation trick
or could I get away without it?
And you can get away without it.
This is an idea
of Therese Biedl.
This is my Waterloo days.
We had an open problem
session, kind of like the one
we have in this class.
It was the very
first one that I ran.
I ran it with Therese.
And she came up with this idea.
This is a-- it's not obvious
exactly how this works
or where she came up with this.
It was kind of magical.
But this the same polygon,
different creases, you
make two different size boxes.
Now they're going to be integers
because they're orthogonal
aligned on the grid.
Pretty cool.
And for a long time, this
was the only example of this
that we had.
There's still an open question
which I give you A by C by-- A
by B by C box and a D by E
by F box, is this possible?
When is this possible?
But at least now--
oh, here's, sorry.
There are two examples.
Of course, the surface
areas have to match.
So the sum of A plus B plus
C equals D plus E plus F.
I think that's right.
Or no.
It's more complicated.
It's like A times
B plus-- and so on.
Pairwise products.
Now we know that
there are actually
infinitely many examples.
This is another fairly
new result by Uehara,
again in 2008.
This is-- Uehara translated
our textbook to Japanese,
by the way.
Another connection.
He does a lot of
fun folding stuff.
Just saw him last week.
So this is an
example of taking a 1
by 5 by 2k box and a common
unfolding of that with a 1
by 1 by 6k plus 2 box.
Which has a very
regular pattern.
And this one, little more
complicated to copy and paste
but it makes 1 by 1 by 8k
plus 11 box and a 1 by 3
by 4k plus 5 box.
Which is pretty cool.
I haven't studied
these carefully,
but there's two different
ways to fold each.
So now we know
there are infinitely
many of these examples.
It's still not known
when it's possible,
but also in this
paper Uehara came up
with a sort of random
generation algorithm
where he would take a
box, randomly unfold
it, try to fold it
into other boxes.
And he has now over 250,000
examples of this process.
And I think these are maybe
inspired by his random search.
I'm not sure, but this
is theory obviously.
One particularly fun
example, this one
actually tiles the plane.
So it'd be efficient
if you're cutting it
out of sheet material.
You can make a common unfolding
of 1 by 2 by 5 box and a 1
by 1 by 8 box.
I think this one he
made into a puzzle
with a paper manufacturer.
I'm getting ahead of myself.
Big open question
here that he asked is,
are there-- is there a common
unfolding of three boxes?
That remains open.
And he feels like he's
very close to finding one
with his random search
but hasn't yet found one.
It's like it almost
folds into the third box.
But it's strange how
hard it is to find them.
Maybe they don't exist.
That would be surprising.
All right.
Next example on this theme,
common unfoldings, is this toy.
So this is a 1 by 1 by 4 box,
also known as the-- as a tetra
cubes, four cubes
joined edge to edge.
And-- oh, I should
have practiced.
You can unfold it.
This is a commercially
produced toy.
It's called Cubigami.
And it's one net, one unfolding.
But it can fold into
all tetra cubes.
So that was the tube and, let's
see, what else can I make here?
I should have practiced.
Interesting.
It's fun.
You can play with it later.
Oh, that looks interesting.
Almost.
Not quite.
It's almost-- it looks
like a Tetris piece, right?
Except I didn't quite
cover it right at the end.
It's a good puzzle.
Obviously.
Maybe if I do it like--
that doesn't work.
Wow.
All right.
You're going to have to
play with it yourself.
I lose.
But you can make all of
the four cube joinings
except-- except for this one.
See, the problem
with this example
is it doesn't have the same
surface areas the rest.
And you have to
conserve surface area.
But if you think about
all the other four
cubes-- like I was trying to
make this guy or this guy--
it's like Tetris
pieces-- but also things
like-- I can draw
better than I can
solve the puzzle apparently.
Like this.
This is the one non-planar one.
All right?
So you've got all the Tetris
pieces except this guy.
It's the wrong surface area.
So, in general, it's
all the tree shape ones.
No cycles.
Can make all of them.
This is an example found by
Donald Knuth, famous computer
scientist.
He sort of accidentally
at a cocktail party heard
about this problem from George
Miller who's a toy designer--
or puzzle designer.
And so then Knuth
went back and he
wrote a program to numerate
all unfoldings of these things
and found there are a whole
bunch of common unfoldings.
But it's found by
exhaustive search.
This was the one that sort of
had the smallest bounding box,
I believe, in terms of area.
And so it's a nice
compact thing.
And then there are various
manufacturing's of it.
This is the latest one that's
sort of relatively easy
to build I guess.
So, play with that later.
That's four cubes.
What about five cubes?
Well, that was the subject
of a paper also presented
last week in China.
And it turns out, there
is no common unfolding
of all 24 pentacubes.
That's five cubes
joined together.
But there is a common unfolding
of 23 out of 24 of them.
So this is the paper.
There was a bunch of authors.
There were basically
three teams that
worked on this, two of
which were writing code.
I was on one of
the coding teams.
And the third one
was trying to think
about the problem
using mathematics.
And for a long time, the
thinkers were leading.
But then, of course,
eventually the computers
win because after a couple days
of just solid computation on I
don't know now how many cores
with each of the groups,
we numerated all
these unfoldings.
And so now there's, I think,
over one trillion unfoldings
of the 1 by 1 by 5 tube.
But one trillions not that bad.
Now, we could not
do this for six.
But for five it wasn't so bad.
And this is-- there's a bunch
of unfoldings of 23 out of 24.
But that's the max you can get.
Little disappointing.
AUDIENCE: Which pentacube lost?
PROFESSOR: I don't know
which pentacube lost.
I should find out.
That's a good question.
But I do have some
other answers.
So in some sense,
the hard ones I think
are the non-planar guys.
Like this guy.
So they're planar
if all the cubes
lie in a thickened
plane, thickened by one.
This guy will fold into
all the non-planar cubes
and also fold into
most of the pentacubes.
There are only 24 total
so it's only missing two.
And this'll fold into
all the non-planar guys.
And what's cool is
this one is unique.
There's only one common
unfolding of those guys.
AUDIENCE: How many
non-planar [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: How many
non-planar are there?
I don't remember.
Maybe 10.
I think it's a minority.
But there are still
a bunch of them.
And I think this would
make a good puzzle.
If you're going to
manufacture-- if you guys want
to do a start up, here you go.
Freely available.
If you want to do
the planar pentacubes
there are a lot of common
unfoldings of them.
This is one of the
fairly compact ones.
And this one, I have
an animation of.
Or, actually, not
this particular
unfolding, but this concept.
And that is here.
Yes, I trust myself.
So here is unfolding
and re-folding
of that particular shape.
And then I hit
Space bar and it's
the same unfolding but
a different polycube.
And this is going to go
through all of the flat ones.
And that animation is
done heuristically.
I don't have any theory
that that's always possible.
But always keeping
the same unfolding,
just changing where
the creases are.
That's so cool.
It's funny, actually.
The person who implemented this
was the guy who was thinking,
not the coder-- coder teams.
I guess he had free time.
This is by [? Karim ?]
[INAUDIBLE].
I guess you can count them
and then subtract from 24
and you'll get how many
non-planar ones there are.
But I've lost track
of where we are.
Always same unfolding.
This is a fairly nice,
simple unfolding.
It's mostly one dimensional.
All right.
You get the idea, right?
Pretty fun.
All right.
So, right.
Do I have anymore?
I think that was the
end of my slides.
I do have one more example in
the notes which is, if you just
want to make the flat
guys-- so just the two
dimensional
examples-- so we know
we could do that with five,
but you can also do with six.
We wrote another
program that looks
at a very special
kind of unfolding.
And in that special class,
it's possible to fold
all planar six
cubes-- hexacubes.
But that class does not work
for septacubes-- seven cubes.
Open question, is there
a common unfolding
of all planar seven cubes or
all non-planar seven cubes?
Or how many can you make?
There it was beyond exhaustion,
and we have to actually think.
Unless you come up with
a good class and then
you can exhaust
it in that class.
One nice open question here
is, if you go to large N,
are there some two polycubes
that have no common unfolding?
At the moment, it
could be every pair
of polycubes has a
common unfolding.
Certainly there
are-- for example,
in this class there
are four polycubes that
do not have a common unfolding.
I think we're not
sure about three.
For size five.
Of course, we don't even
know whether there's
any polycube that
has no unfolding.
I think there should be one.
But at the moment, it
could be every polycube
has an unfolding.
But to make it a little harder,
what about two polycubes
at once you want a
common unfolding?
All these questions are open.
All right.
This is common unfolding.
We're going to stick
with unfolding stuff
but change around the
problem a little bit.
So let me ask you a question.
Can have a vote for those who
haven't read the notes already
and know the answer.
So let's say,
orthogonal polyhedron.
We talk a lot about
orthogonal polyhedra.
See all this polycube
stuff is in that genre.
And so way back when we
talked about grid unfolding
of orthogonal polyhedra.
It's not known whether
that's possible,
but we have epsilon
unfolding where
you cut exponentially
many times and so on.
But how do you define
orthogonal polyhedra?
There are two
natural definitions.
One is that the
angles are right.
Right angles, let's
say, in the faces.
The other natural definition
is that you look at two faces
and the angles between
those should be right.
So I guess right
dihedral angles.
Right face angles or
right dihedral angles.
The question is, are
these the same thing?
Who thinks yes?
Who thinks no?
Yeah.
I kind of set it up.
Everyone thinks no.
They're not the same.
But for genus zero
polyhedra, they are the same.
That's maybe the
surprising thing.
This is a genus
eight polyhedron.
No, seven.
It's always a little
tricky to measure genus.
If it just had one triangular
face that would be-- well,
anyway, that's genus seven.
I'm not going to
try to convince you.
This is an unfolding
of the thing.
So you can see,
in the unfolding,
it looks like it's an
orthogonal polyhedron.
All the angles are right.
It looks perfect.
And yet, it folds into
this non-orthogonal thing.
Kind of a thickened octahedron.
It's kind of critical that it
has a genus more than zero.
In this paper-- this
is the original paper
that considered this problem--
there's a lower bound of one.
The genus 0 is not enough.
Then we came along-- I don't
have the author list here.
It's with the Waterloo gang, it
was Therese Biedl and others.
And this is a smaller genus,
a genus six polyhedron.
This guy.
So it's almost the same
example turned inside out.
So this like to half
octahedra and then joined
in this cubicle frame
and then you put caps
on the cubicle frame to make
there not be holes out there.
And then you have
slightly smaller genus
because you can go
around the backside.
So that's the best known,
is a genus six example.
We proved that you need
genus at least three
in order for such
an example to exist.
I have a little sketch
of the proof in the notes
if you want to read it.
It's a fun little boot
strapping argument but I would--
I'm going to go on
to other fun topics
here rather than prove this.
Is that a good plan?
I think that's good plan.
OK.
So this is a fun
kind of-- unfoldings
can be orthogonal while the
three dimensional versions are
not orthogonal.
All right.
Next topic.
I'm going to go back to
Alexandrov's theorem.
Turns out there is a
smooth version of that.
So now we're going
to segue a little bit
into smooth foldings
and smooth unfoldings.
So instead of thinking of
polyhedron objects-- polygons
and convex polyhedra-- I want
to think about smooth bodies.
So, for example, suppose
I take a smooth convex
shape like an
ellipse or something
and I picked two
perimeter antipodes
and I do perimeter having
gluing where this is defines--
as I walk along the
perimeter in both directions
it-- I obviously
didn't do it perfectly,
they should meet at
exactly the same time.
This defines a gluing.
For every point there
is a corresponding point
it gets glued to.
This is a way to make what is
locally like a convex surface
because at any point, at
most 360 degrees of material
is glued there because
this thing was convex.
And the same way as
for convex polygons,
does this make a convex
something in three dimensions?
It's not going to make
a polyhedron because it
has this curve,
but indeed it does
make a convex smooth surface.
So every convex metric
that's topologically a sphere
is realized by a
unique convex surface.
So Alexandrov's theorem was
identical to this statement
except it also had
polyhedral up here,
that there were finite number
of points of nonzero curvature.
Now we have
infinitely many points
of slightly positive
curvature because, again, this
is supposed to sum to 4 pi.
That's still true.
But it's now an integral
instead of a sum.
So each of these things sort of
has an infinitesimal curvature
and if you integrate
them it adds up to 4 pi.
You can check that.
So this will make something.
I encourage you to try
this out, again, with tape.
You're going to
approximate it because tape
is going to be polygonal.
But it works.
It will make something.
I particularly-- I should
mention the idea of this proof
is just to take limits
of regular Alexandrov.
Take closer and closer
polyhedral approximations.
In the polyhedral world
we can use that induction
that we talked about.
In the smooth case, you
can't, but the smooth case
is the limit of the polyhedral
case so it works out.
This is proved by a student
of Alexandrov Pogorelov
in the '70s, whereas he
proved his theorem in the '40s
or '50s.
One really fun thing you
could do with this theorem
is, instead of using
just one convex shape,
you could use two convex shapes
and zip them to each other.
And this is called a D-form.
It was invented by an
artist, Tony Wills.
So here I've taken
two-- in this case,
two identical
convect shapes-- they
don't have to be identical--
picked two points to glue them
to each other and then you
just zip around the perimeter.
And again, because you're always
gluing convex angles to convex
angles-- the smooth
convex angles--
but they're still less than
180, so you glue them together,
it's less than 360.
And in this case, it's-- we
could actually figure out
and think about what 3D shape
you get so we could build that
in Mathematica.
But in general, you get
some weird convex shape.
For a while there were
some examples of this
but no one knew exactly
what they looked like.
Then, I think it was a
project in this class
or it came out of the problem
session in this class three
years ago, Greg
Price and I proved
that these things
are nice in the sense
that the only place
you get creases
is along the seam,
the pink stuff.
Both for-- these
are called D-forms,
these have another-- I
think these are pita-forms,
if I recall, where you take one
convex shape instead of two.
Here you only get--
you can get the creases
along the seam and
one extra crease,
if I recall correctly here.
And here you don't
get any extra creases.
It's always smooth
except at the seam.
And also, if you just take
the seam-- the pink part--
and take the convex hull of that
thing, you get the same thing.
So it doesn't go outside.
It's really tightly
wrapped around wherever
the seam happens to go.
Remember, this thing is
unique by Pogorelov's theorem.
So it's kind of nice to
know that structurally these
are pretty nice and smooth.
If your original shapes
are smooth convex bodies,
you will get a
nice, smooth shape
at the end that only has
creases at the seams.
Cool.
Again, please try to it at home.
It's lots of fun.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Let's see.
This point should glue to here.
I mean, it's
perfectly symmetric.
AUDIENCE: I'm looking
at the 3D form.
PROFESSOR: The 3D form.
So one of the two shapes
is here and the other one
is here and goes around
the back to there.
And it's, again, symmetric.
This is a nice example because
we have those parallel lines.
Usually you wouldn't have that.
And they're harder to
draw, is the challenge.
Here, obviously,
we're doing sort
of a polygonal approximation.
You see all the lines.
All right.
This is a smooth version of
folding-- a smooth version
of Alexandrov's theorem.
We can also think about
smooth versions of unfolding.
So here there is
exactly one paper
by Nadia Benbernou whose in
the front row and Heather--
AUDIENCE: Patricia.
PROFESSOR: Patricia
Khan and Joe O'Rourke.
So this is a prismatoid.
It's a little hard to
see the bottom face
but there's a convex polygon on
the bottom, a parallel convex
polygon on the top.
You take the convex hull--
sorry, they're not polygons.
They're smooth convex bodies.
So you've got one in the floor
plane, one in a parallel plane
up top.
You take the convex hull, you
get this nice smooth thing
around the outside.
Now, we have to generalize
our notion of unfolding
because normally with
unfolding this would take
an infinite number of cuts
to-- we have to cut everywhere
there's curvature.
Which means we're going
to have to cut along
all those black lines.
Which means we slice the thing
into very infinitesimal pieces.
But if you think
of it as a limit
of regular polyhedral things--
here I have a little example.
Let's think about the limit in
a simpler example to start with.
So imagine you want
to take a pyramid--
so the top poly-- the top
convex shape is just a point.
I guess it looks like
a cone but down here
it could be anything, could be
an ellipse or any convex shape.
Well, we can think of this as
a polyhedral approximation.
So, for example, we take
a hexagon on the bottom,
we want to unfold that.
And in particular, we
thought about these--
these are the
pyramids-- and we--
one of the unfoldings of
them is the volcano unfolding
if you remember back to
the unfolding lecture.
Looks like that.
All these triangles just fold
out, get all those parts.
That never overlaps,
it's sort of trivial.
You take the limit of that.
In the limit, the floor becomes
whatever the convex shape.
Maybe-- let's think about the
simple case where it's a disk.
And in the limit you're getting
lots of really tiny triangles.
You take that all the way to
limit, what you're getting
is actually a concentric
circle around there.
So really, these
become segments.
Now, what's funny about
this limit is, normally--
before you get to the end, you
see there's these big gaps.
A lot of the area's missing.
These things are getting
infinitesimally small
and yet they have to
spread over this big range.
So most of this area
is actually absent.
When you take the limit you
can't really see that anymore.
It just becomes filled in.
And so in this unfolding,
the area of the green stuff,
if you just took that area
measured on the floor,
it's going to be larger
than the area in the pink.
So this is not an area
preserving unfolding
which makes it a little weird.
But it's still well defined.
I mean, you wouldn't
actually-- well,
for example-- we're going
to get to this in a moment--
if you actually took material
like this out of, say,
tin foil, something
that can crinkle,
then you should be able to
crinkle it into this shape.
I'll talk about
how to prove that.
That's actually most of
the rest of the lecture,
is about that kind
of notion of folding.
It's more like origami,
though, than unfolding
because you're sort of
over covering stuff.
And here-- actually,
here the hard part
is not so much to show
these ribs don't intersect,
although they don't and
it's not totally obvious
because here they're kind
of going towards each other.
But they won't actually
intersect in the unfolding.
One of the tricky parts is to
show that the top face actually
can fit somewhere,
so you actually
get an unfolding of this thing.
And I forget, this is choosing
some kind of extreme rib
and putting it out there.
It's a nice line of
separation if I recall.
This is funny because here we
have a limit of some process.
Now, for pyramids we know
the volcano unfolding works.
For prismatoids,
regular prismatoids
are when you take
some convex polygon
and some other parallel convex
polygon, take the convex hull.
We don't know whether
these have edge unfoldings.
Still an open problem.
And yet, for the
smooth case, we do.
Kind of magical.
I know why that's true.
It's somehow the edge
constraint is harder.
If you're not just worried
about edge unfoldings,
we do know how to
unfold those obviously.
You can do star unfolding,
source unfolding.
Here, edge unfolding--
well, we have
to cut along all those
infinitely many edges.
That makes it easier,
much smoother.
But it's funny when the
smooth case is actually
easier than the discrete case.
All right.
The next problem I want to
talk about is chocolate.
I have here a bunch of
spherical chocolates.
The most-- apparently the only
perfectly spherical chocolate,
at least according
to the advertisement,
is this thing called
the Mozart Kugel.
Now, Mozart Kugel-- how many
people have eaten them before.
Just a couple.
Good stuff.
It's, I guess, more
a European thing.
It's from Austria.
It's invented in early
1900s, I forget exactly when.
It was a big thing at the
time because making chocolate
perfectly spherical is not easy.
It's like, how do
you hold it and not
get little indentations?
This thing is
perfectly spherical.
Here I'll show you.
But, really, the question I
wonder, because as an origamist
you wonder, how do
you wrap this thing?
Oh, I ripped it.
I'll try to do this
more carefully.
It's not how you usually
eat chocolate, is it?
Open very carefully.
It's OK.
I have more in case I fail.
More chocolate.
Not enough for you, I'm afraid.
So ignore the chocolate.
It's not the Droid
you're looking for.
It's not the chocolate.
So it's a rectangle.
I didn't do a perfect job.
There's a few
little tears there.
But they fold-- Mirabell.
Mirabell makes the most
Mozart Kugel in the world.
Mozart Kugel is very
cool because it's
built in-- built up
in concentric spheres.
You have the marzipan layer,
then the milk chocolate layer,
then the nougat layer, then
the dark chocolate layer,
if I recall.
Each brand has a
different recipe,
but they're always
spherical on the outside.
It's kind of like
glassblowing actually.
It's kind of fun.
And each company has a
slightly different way-- well,
I've studied only
two main companies.
Mirabell makes the most of them
but they are not the original.
They are called the
echta which is--
AUDIENCE: The real.
PROFESSOR: The real.
The authentic.
But-- now, these
are hard to come by.
These are brought to me by
my student, [INAUDIBLE],
some of you know.
Architecture.
This is the-- oh,
it says in English.
It's kind of easy.
The original Salzburger
Mozart Kugel.
Mozart was-- lived
in Salzburg, I guess.
And so this is named after him.
Oh, 1884.
Wow.
So that's when they started.
Now, these guys--
I think I've only
had like one of
these in my life.
I'm really excited.
The Mirabell's are
OK, but this stuff?
Wow.
Oh, it's so much
easier to unfold.
I like-- this is, I
think, probably handmade.
Much more handmade.
In fact, you can kind of tell
it's not perfectly spherical.
It has a little nub at the top.
So this is probably more how
they were originally made.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: What, are
you getting hungry?
Now, Furst-- Furst
is the company
who made the first Mozart
Kugel-- they use squares.
I claim they're a
little bit better.
But interesting question is,
which uses more material?
Something to think about.
Meanwhile-- I won't
torture you more by eating.
All right.
So this is a Mozart
Kugel problem.
This paper started when-- I
think we are in New Orleans.
Some part of the gang
was in New Orleans
and there was this
deadline the next day
and it was for this workshop
on computational geometry--
the European workshop--
and it happened
to be in Austria that
year-- that coming year.
We're like, what
paper could we write?
And we're sitting there
in the little cafe eating
these beignets of
doughnuts and thinking,
what could we write
a paper about?
It's like, how about food?
And what does Austria have?
Well, [SPEAKING GERMAN]
Well, how about Mozart Kugel?
So-- this is how
research happens.
But it's really cool.
It's really cool because
this is not your--
this is not the origami you
grew up with in this class.
Because you can't fold a
sphere out of a square paper.
And yet, this was a square
folded into a sphere.
Somehow that was done using
a finite amount of effort.
Whereas if you use regular
paper to fold something
that has positive
curvature everywhere,
you need infinitely
many creases.
And yet this is fairly
practical to do.
This is hand wrapped.
In theory, I could re-wrap this.
I've never actually tried.
But something like this.
It works pretty well.
I even covered the tip.
How did I do that
in finite effort?
Well, of course it's
not a perfect sphere.
But we need to model
this mathematically.
It's annoying to
take approximations.
I would like a model of
folding that actually
does make it possible
to fold a sphere.
So this is the idea of
contractive folding.
We haven't been super rigorous
about defining origami,
but I always say you
take a piece of paper,
you can't stretch the paper,
you can't tear the paper,
and you can't self-intersect.
We're going to relax the
you can't stretch the paper.
You still can't
stretch the paper,
but now the paper can contract.
So it can't get longer
but it can get shorter.
It's like cables from
tensegrity theory.
So you take any pair of points.
There's some distance as
measured on the piece of paper.
When you fold this thing
into your awesome sphere,
you take the two points,
you measure the distance
along the surface of
the piece of paper.
Now, I'll-- normally
with origami,
these two distances
should be equal.
That's isometry.
That's regular origami.
But if I say that this one--
so write equal that way.
If this one can be smaller,
then this is contractive.
And that is paper that can
shrink but not stretch.
So pairwise distances
don't increase.
So they could stay the same.
We could still do
regular origami.
But we can also contract.
And then it is possible
to fold a sphere.
Now, intuitively,
what's going on
is, when you fold out of
tinfoil, you can crinkle.
And that lets you not have
to worry about-- I mean,
this is pretty good
approximation to a sphere
especially when I have
a good base underneath
to approximate against.
I'm doing lots of little
tiny creases in order
to approximate that contractive
mapping, contractive folding.
So, conveniently,
there's a theorem
that tells us this
is always possible.
I'll tell you the theorem.
This is another theorem
by Burago and Zalgallar
who proved the other
theorem that if you
have any polyhedral
metric you can turn it
into some polyhedron,
not necessarily convex.
So they solved that problem
plus they solved this problem.
If you take a contractive-- they
only solved the smooth case.
I imagine this works
for piecewise smooth.
You take a contractive
C2 immersion--
it's just some fancy
word for folding,
it has some extra constraints
but let's not worry about it.
So C2 means continuous up
to the second derivative.
So nice and smooth.
Spheres are valid, for example.
Then any one of those
things has a C0--
I'll just call it
polyhedral approximation.
And this is approximation
in the Hausdorff sense
meaning you want
to fold the sphere.
If you just thicken that
sphere by some epsilon,
then you can sort of stay within
that epsilon thickened sphere
and do some kind of wiggling.
You'll be polyhedral
and you'll only
have finitely many creases.
So there-- if you have a nice,
smooth contracted folded state,
you could turn it into a regular
origami isometry folded state
that's arbitrarily
close to the sphere.
So for any epsilon.
So that's a convenient
theorem from 1996.
So that's the model.
Now we can think about, how
do I optimally wrap a sphere?
Now, there are
many possible goals
you might want to optimize
in wrapping a sphere.
Presumably, you want your
shape to tile the plane.
So you can cut out a
whole bunch of these out
of one sheet of tinfoil.
Obviously Mirabell
likes rectangles,
Furst likes squares.
Are those the
right things to do?
What about triangles?
What about other shapes?
These are the sorts of
questions we consider.
We don't have a complete
answer to this question.
But we have a lot of
fun-- fun things to do.
What should I tell
you about first?
I'm getting hungry.
Maybe I'll have the
rest of that Mirabell.
It's just sitting there.
Half a Mozart Kugel,
can't have that.
All right.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yes.
Question?
AUDIENCE: I was wondering--
PROFESSOR: You can have any.
AUDIENCE: Because of
the fact that you've
got this contracting
that occurs,
I was wondering-- it's obvious
that because of contracting
you need more than 4 pi
r surface area of paper
to wrap a sphere--
a one unit sphere.
I'm wondering, do you
know exactly how much
paper do you require due to
the fact that [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Good question.
How much paper do you require?
Area is not being
preserved here.
Just like the continuous
unfolding stuff,
you don't preserve area.
This is really the same thing.
I think you can prove
this is a contractive map.
So if you had this
as a piece of paper,
you really could fold
that smooth pyramid.
But you lose material when
you do a contractive mapping.
And in the inverse, when you're
unfolding, you gain material.
How much material
do I have to gain?
Think about it.
You should be able to
answer that question.
I'm going to tell you about some
stuff while you think about it.
That was the original
question we started with.
What's the minimum area
wrapping of a unit sphere?
The surface area of a
sphere is 4 pi, FYI.
How much more do you need?
All right.
To describe these unfoldings,
I guess they are, or wrappings,
whichever way you're
thinking about going,
it's useful to have
some structure, kind
of a backbone to the unfolding.
So we came up with this
idea of stretched path.
And you can show that any
kind of optimal wrapping
will have at least
one stretch path.
And our idea is
actually-- let me tell you
what a stretch path is.
This is a, let's say, a
path between two vertices
whose length does not decrease.
So it actually is
preserved in the folding.
So I have my sphere,
I have two points,
take the shortest
path between them.
That shortest path
is exactly what
it is in the unfolding,
exactly the same length.
So that's what we
call a stretch path.
There's no crinkling
along that path.
There maybe crinkling on
either side of the path,
but not on it.
Our idea is-- OK, that gives
you some kind of structure.
Our idea is to completely
cover the surface
of the sphere with
stretched paths.
There's a lot of
ways you can do that.
Some of them will be valid,
some of them won't be.
The simplest one is
the source unfolding.
Or I guess you could call
it the source wrapping.
Wrapping somehow means
contractive I guess.
Which is, you take your
sphere, take some point x,
you take all the
shortest paths around x--
it's a little tricky to draw.
In other words, the Voronoi
diagram at that point.
Just like we did with
source unfolding.
And you call all of these edges,
all those straight lines--
geodesics, whatever-- they go to
this opposite south pole here.
All of those lines you
call stretch paths.
That determines an unfolding.
And it happens to
be contractive.
The unfolding will be a
big disk because you'll
have the center-- call this x.
This is 3D, this is 2D,
in case it wasn't clear.
They both look the same.
But now all those
paths are straight.
And it's clear what the
lengths of these paths are.
Each one of them is
half the circumference.
Circumference?
Is that what you call it?
Half of an equator
of the sphere.
Which for a unit sphere is pi.
So this is radius pi, which
means the area of this thing
is pi r squared.
Sorry, the area is pi cubed.
Interesting.
But pi cubed, you can
compute, is more than 4pi.
Pi squared is
almost-- is over nine.
It's over nine times pi.
We want four times pi.
This is an example of
not preserving area.
What's happening is
there's lots of crinkling
between these lines.
Now, there are infinitely
many of these lines.
Every point is covered by
one of these stretched paths.
But again, when I
unfold them, if I
did a limiting approximation,
there'd be lots of holes here.
But in the limit
there are no holes
and that's where
I waste material
I get contraction.
Make sense?
I actually brought a
sphere, a couple spheres.
I brought some chocolate
spheres, but slightly bigger
sphere so we can
think about this.
In this case, we're making
stretch paths all around
from the north pole
down to the south pole
and kind of cutting
at the south pole.
And that's it.
All right.
Has anyone solved the problem
of what the minimum area
wrapping of the sphere is?
Yeah?
You solved it?
Janine.
Or an idea.
AUDIENCE: I think
it's 4pi plus epsilon.
PROFESSOR: 4pi plus
epsilon is correct.
How do you want to do it?
Exactly.
AUDIENCE: An apple
core-- or peeling.
PROFESSOR: Apple peeling, yes.
Or I prefer to think
of it as lecturer--
I don't know which one--
the one about strip folding.
AUDIENCE: Oh, yeah.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
Exactly.
So we had this result
about strip folding
if you remember way back in
the folding anything lecture.
We talked about this
and then orgamizer.
This was the inefficient method.
But if you started with a
very long rectangle of paper,
we could show that the
area of that piece of paper
is arbitrary-- could
be made arbitrarily
close to the area
of your polyhedron.
So that area plus some epsilon.
And you can make
epsilon as small
as you wanted just by
making this polygon longer.
If you take a polyhedral
approximation of a sphere
and apply this theorem, you'll
get very close to the surface
area of that approximation which
is very close to the surface
area of the sphere,
which is 4pi.
And then, if you take
an outer approximation,
then you can just sort of
crinkle all those vertices down
against the sphere.
And you'll do-- it's
maybe not totally obvious,
but it's not that hard.
You get a contractive map that
actually wraps the sphere using
not much more surface
area than what you had.
The same as what you
had, which was not
much more than the sphere.
So you can get 4pi plus epsilon.
So it turns out, minimizing
the area of your wrapping
is not that interesting
a question by itself
because there's kind of
this cheating solution.
Obviously, you don't
want to manufacture that.
I don't think.
Maybe she built a robot, did
the inverse orange peeling,
it would be pretty cool.
But if you're trying to sell
this idea to confectioners
around the world, I
wouldn't recommend
attempting strip folding.
So we would like
something that's
reasonably nice but-- yeah.
OK.
AUDIENCE: So if
you're trying sell
wrapper companies [INAUDIBLE]
square or rectangular amounts
would these be 4pi squared?
Because you're basically
producing something
that maybe would expand
the circumference and--
PROFESSOR: Well, OK, an
interesting question is,
what is the surface
area of these wrappings?
These actually have
pretty special properties,
the rectangle and
the-- I'm getting
hungry-- and the square.
Have you thought about which
of these has more surface area?
The rectangle has more?
Who thinks the
rectangle has more?
Who thinks the square has more?
Who thinks they're the same?
Seed you with that idea.
Well, they're actually the same.
I'll explain why
in a little bit.
It's crazy, I know.
I prefer the square because
it has less perimeter.
There are obviously many
things you might not
like about this strip folding.
It has high aspect
ratio, but in particular,
one way to characterize
why this is nasty,
it says high perimeter.
Perimeter is annoying
because-- for a few reasons.
Intuitively, if you
started with the sphere
and you wanted to
cut it open, then you
need a lot of cutting
because the perimeter is
the amount that you cut.
Or it's twice that.
So conversely, when you're
trying to wrap a surface,
if you have high
perimeter, there's
a lot to worry about, lots of
things that have to match up.
So you've got to be very
careful in your crinkling.
Whereas I really didn't
have to be very careful
wrapping with the square
because it has low perimeter.
Another sense in which
perimeter is annoying
is you're going to
have some error.
So in fact, you can't just
perfectly wrap a sphere.
Like, if I took a disk
of exactly this size,
I probably couldn't
wrap a sphere with it
because I'm going to
lose just some epsilon
and then there'll
be a little point
around the south
pole that's missing.
If you're really going to
build confectionery-- build
confectionery-- if you're really
going to wrap confectionery,
you probably make this
a little bit bigger.
How much area do
you lose when you
make your thing a
little bit bigger?
Well, it's roughly the
perimeter times epsilon.
It's a little bit different from
that, but basically perimeter
times epsilon.
So if you minimize
perimeter, then
your area wastage from
double coverage will go down.
So really what I
want is something
that's low area
and low perimeter.
That's our new goal.
And that's why I like
Furst better than Mirabell,
not just because
they taste better.
I really should verify
that they taste better.
Oh, yeah.
Now, they're very
different insides.
Oh, but it's so good.
Oh, much better chocolate.
All right.
Maybe I should have a
lottery for eating the rest.
Petal wrapping.
This is going to be
another way to put stretch
paths on the sphere and
get an unfolding-- get
a contractive
wrapping from that.
Which actually
corresponds to this toy.
I don't know if you
ever played with this.
The Frisbee that's also a ball.
These-- you see those cuts?
Those are the shortest
paths from the north
pole to the south pole.
But we're not--
before we were sort
of using-- kind of slicing
along but also preserving--
that's kind of confusing--
all of them, infinitely many.
Now I want to do
with finitely many.
Here I only have six.
Six?
Yes, six.
Doesn't have to be six.
Could be any number k.
So I'm going to look at k
stretch paths from north pole
to south pole.
So I have my sphere,
here is my north pole.
I do some constant number.
Here I've done five.
This is equally spaced
angular around the north pole,
they all go to the south
pole on the bottom.
Something like that.
It's going to start
getting messy.
These are going to
be stretch paths.
I have to fill these orange
slices in between them.
How should I fill them?
Here's an idea.
It's kind of like
the Voronoi diagram.
Voronoi diagram is you grow from
many objects simultaneously.
With this sphere wrapping
we grew from a single point
in all directions.
That was it.
Now, I've drawn these paths.
What if I grew from all of these
finite stretch paths at once?
What I would get, these
would at some point converge.
They would converge at
the angular bisector here.
Along the way,
what's happening is
each of these points is kind of
tracing along a straight line,
so to speak, a
great circular arc
until it reaches that point.
I'm going to make
these stretched paths,
and these are also stretched
pads, and basically cutting
along the dotted line.
OK.
I won't draw all of them.
But you get the idea.
When you unfold this thing, you
have these kind of wish bones.
These guys meet sort
of perpendicularly.
So when you unfold you
preserve those angles.
Remember these are
stretched paths.
These lengths are preserved.
The stuff in between,
it's really a curved thing
and it gets slightly
larger in this thing.
We call this thing a petal.
But this is an
unfolding of this sort
of one fifth of the sphere.
This is the center line and
these are the two sides.
So that's the idea
of petal wrapping.
Now, there's different ways
to join these petals together.
One idea is join them
all at the north pole.
So then what you get--
it's a little hard
to imagine that these things
don't intersect each other,
especially when I've
drawn them so fat.
For five, it's going to
look something like this.
I'm drawing it perfectly.
They won't actually
intersect in the center
because the total amount
of material at the center
is only 360 degrees.
And this will actually have--
the tangents will actually
match up here.
So they will perfectly
mean in the center
without self-intersection.
So it's only sort of
a vertex unfolding.
Because they're only
connected at the single point.
But that's maybe necessary.
I don't know.
And again, these are
the stretched paths.
It's a neat way to
think about unfolding.
You can draw these--
ignore the yellow for now.
That's if you might want
to actually cut these out.
So we have the three
petal unfolding, the four
petal unfolding, five
petal unfolding, six petal,
you can go arbitrarily high.
In the limit, the
area of the blue stuff
will converge to 4pi.
This is another way to
get arbitrarily close.
Because the smaller
these things are,
the less you're distorting.
So this is two
families of wrappings.
We call these-- the blue
stuff is the petal unfolding,
the yellow is the convex
hull of the petal unfoldings.
Not quite, actually.
So in the case of k equals 3,
we could think about a convex
hull, but what I've drawn
here is the smallest
enclosing equilateral triangle.
Now this is the first
class of unfoldings
we came up with after
the obvious sphere--
or circular one which
had pi cubed over 9pi.
One thing we wondered
is that triangle,
is it better than the
Mozart Kugel wrappings?
Or is it worse?
One way or the
other, presumably.
Or maybe it's the same again.
Who knows.
Let's see.
Yeah.
Let me tell you, at this point--
so I need more techniques
to cover both of
those unfoldings,
but that square is
the first wrapping.
This one.
I'll have to unfold another
one just so you can see.
All right.
So you see-- I mean,
I did a few times
so maybe you already know.
Here I have four corners,
four right angles.
They meet at the top.
So that is-- that's
where the four
corners of the
square which are also
the four corners of the
petal come together.
And then it's just
everything-- these lines
are stretched paths.
There's no distortion around
them, they just kind of unfold.
The stuff in the middle is--
it's like undressing here.
It's so tantalizing.
The stuff in the middle
is getting contracted.
So if-- I don't know if you
could see, maybe in the video
you'll be able to see.
Look closely at here.
Along this path there
isn't so much crinkling.
In between there's a
lot more crinkling.
It's like here there's
a lot of crinkling.
When I unfold it,
a lot more stuff
happens in between
the four top paths.
OK?
Now, they wanted to
cut very simple shapes.
In particular, shapes
that tiled the plane.
So they ended up using squares
instead of the sort of optimal
with that stretched paths
which are those four petals.
So they used the yellow,
whereas you could just
get away with the blue.
Of course, you want to add
a little bit of material
in the center so it
doesn't fall apart.
And you need to thicken
the edges a little bit.
So they care about that little
yellow minus blue savings?
I'm not sure.
But what about the triangle?
We spend a lot of time
computing these shapes.
It's some weird trigonometry.
It's in the notes.
Arc sine of sine over square
root of 1 over sine squared
minus cos squared of
various parameters
is the description of
one of these curves.
So we did all this
computation and then
we integrated it to compute
what these areas were and then--
or figure out exactly what these
shapes were, take the tangents,
say, well, is the smallest
enclosing triangle better
or worse than the square?
It turns out it's
better by 0.1%.
Now, I think-- millions
of Mozart Kugel
are made every year.
0.1% could equate
to huge savings.
Dollars.
But just think of
the material wastage
that Furst is committing
by using the square.
If they used the
triangle instead,
I mean, this could
solve global warming.
This could solve
chocolate melting.
We actually talk about global
warming in the paper as a joke.
It's a very funny paper.
Very silly paper, I should say.
Right.
Let me tell you
another wrapping.
Chalk.
The comb wrapping.
Comb wrapping, we're going
to use the same idea.
Again-- do I really
want to draw this again?
I'm going to draw those petals,
but instead of connecting them
at the north pole, we're
going to connect them
along the equator.
This is actually what
happens-- oh, no.
This is not-- this connects
them at the north pole I guess,
and it folds them in half.
Whatever.
But I have the equator
nicely denoted here.
So I want to keep the equator
as a new stretched path.
I want that to unfold straight.
But then attached to
it perpendicularly
are all these
petals which unfold.
So the result looks like this.
Here's the equatorial stretched
path and here are the petals.
Petals are exactly the
same shapes as before,
so we still have stretched
pads perpendicular like that.
But it's a new way
to cover every point
on the sphere with
stretched paths.
It leads to the blue unfoldings.
You can take the smallest
enclosing rectangle
and you get the yellow.
What do I want to
say about these?
They're the same
area, of course.
They look a lot like these
old cartograms, cartographs--
whatever you call them--
unfoldings of the earth.
I thought I brought an earth.
Maybe we didn't bring the earth.
A globe, that is.
You've seen pictures
maybe like this.
They're not unfolded
in the same way.
They don't have stretched
paths that are perpendicular.
They use some other
projection, so their petals
are a different shape.
And I'm not sure that
they're contractive--
or inverse contractive maps.
But same spirit anyway.
Let's see.
This one is the
Mirabell unfolding.
Should I unfold another
just to illustrate?
Going through chocolate
like crazy here.
This is the really
hard one to unfold.
So here's one corner--
a little hard to see.
Where's the equator going to be?
I think the equator
is around here.
That make sense?
No.
Actually it should be
perpendicular to that.
Around here.
This is a little harder to see.
Here's a corner, actually.
Tucked inside.
I've been really curious
what kind of robots
they have to do this.
All right.
Here's the equator.
Now I can see it.
So this-- the long
edge of the rectangle
is wrapped around the equator.
See it come off?
And then the corners
are wrapped up
against-- so there's
two-- well, yeah,
these guys go on one side,
these guys go on the other.
That's the short edge
of the rectangle.
Now we can actually compute how
big these things are, right?
So the-- where's the-- I
have a page about this.
Not much.
The vertical length,
that is one half equator.
So that's pi.
The horizontal length is 2pi.
So this is Mirabell
rectangle, pi by 2pi.
And we talked about
the Furst wrapping
which, let's see, this length--
so this goes like this.
So this is 2pi, right?
The diagonal is 2pi.
So that means this edge
length is root 2pi.
By root 2pi.
And magically-- I don't
really have a great reason why
this should be the case
but-- well, maybe I
do-- but these
have the same area.
Both 2pi squared.
Which is like 6pi.
So better than 9ish pi, but
still not quite as good as
4ish pi.
I have some exact numbers.
More exact numbers?
Oh, I have the perimeters.
So the first wrapping, the
perimeter is 5.7 times pi.
And the Mirabell
wrapping is 6 times pi.
So reasonable
savings in perimeter.
2pi squared.
The equilateral
triangle wrapping--
that one in the top left--
instead of 2pi squared,
it has area 1.9983pi squared.
That's the 0.1% improvement.
Amazing.
This was a surprise.
We thought it'd be a fair
amount better or worse
or the same or something.
But almost the same.
It's not what we expected.
Let's see.
I want to go to packing.
What if you want to do better
than those simple convex
shapes?
Yeah, equilateral triangles and
squares and rectangles pack.
But what if I tried to-- what
if I allowed non-convex shapes?
I still want to tile
the plane, so I'm
going to lose some
material for that.
I could add some of this
material to the blue guy, some
to the purple, some to the red.
You can compute the
area of this thing
and it does a lot better than
the equilateral triangle even.
So now we're getting down there.
The perimeter goes up a
little bit, but not by much.
Packing three petals gives
1.6 times pi squared.
Getting better.
By the way, 4pi-- because I'm
going to speak in pi squareds
now-- 4pi is about
1.27pi squared.
OK.
So what we want
is 1.27pi squared.
At this point, we're at
1.6033 times pi squared.
The comb does better.
In the limit, you don't
lose zero here in the limit,
but you lose quite little.
In the limit you get
1.333 times pi squared.
Versus 1.27.
That's pretty good.
I think this is-- this is
what we should manufacture.
Maybe.
Of course, the perimeter
goes to infinity also.
Slight problem.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: You don't
lose zero in the limit.
For awhile we thought we did.
You'll have to think about it.
It's not obvious.
Really, we have this
two dimensional space.
It's called the
Pareto curve or-- it's
a plot of perimeter on
the x-axis versus area
on the y-axis.
We want both to be small.
So two-source
wrapping, for example,
is pretty good in both metrics.
That's where you take the
Voronoi diagram, both the north
and south pole.
So you actually
have two disks-- one
for the southern hemisphere, one
for the northern hemisphere--
you get two disks and you
just attach them side by side.
Although-- yeah.
Let's see.
What's this one?
There's the Furst wrapping.
So they're really good
in terms of perimeter.
In fact, one of the
best perimeters we know.
It's an open problem
how far left you can go.
The stars are convex
hull of petal wrappings.
Because the square was a convex
hull of a four petal wrapping.
This is the convex of
the three petal wrapping.
Now, that doesn't
actually tile, but it
has the smallest
perimeter we now.
So it's where you
take the three petals,
but instead of completing
it to a triangle,
you actually make the sharp
turn around the petal.
So we have three
petals like this.
And so the convex hull
is some tangent here.
And then you follow
the petal for awhile.
And then you take a
tangent, and then you
follow the petal for a while,
and then you take a tangent.
So that's the smallest
perimeter unfolding of a sphere
that we know.
Open problem.
Can you do better?
Can you get arbitrarily small?
Probably not.
Some isoperimetry problem.
You can get arbitrarily
low area, arbitrarily
close to the optimal of 4pi.
That's like the strip wrapping.
Let's see.
So that's one limit.
That corresponds to the limit
of petal or comb wrappings.
Petal and comb wrappings,
if you don't take any hulls
or anything, they are the same
area and the same perimeter.
So I think out of
that you should
be able to see why, in the
special case of the square
and the rectangle, you
get the same stuff.
There's a bijection
between all the parts.
Not totally obvious.
You have to dissect
a little bit.
Mirabell wrappings,
they're not so good.
What are those?
The convex hull
of comb wrappings.
So they're way out here.
Clearly Furst is better.
Here's the equilateral
triangle, which you can't tell,
but it's slightly
below that dashed line.
And pretty good perimeter but
not quite as good as Furst.
So actually, probably, you
don't want to use the triangles.
You prefer the lower perimeter.
But this guy is interesting.
Anyway, this is a fun space.
What we kind of really
care about is-- this
is called the Pareto curve.
It's the, if I give you some
bound on perimeter, what's
the smallest area I can get?
This is the best
bound we know so far.
And we know the Pareto
curves below this thing,
but can you go lower?
We don't know.
So these are some fun examples,
but actually, the big questions
are still pretty
much unsolved here.
Even if you restrict
to-- I think
it's fair to restrict to
wrappings of the sphere
where every point
on the sphere gets
covered by a stretched path.
That seems like a nice,
natural class to think about.
But we have no idea what
that hull space looks like.
Can you do better than
these particular attempts?
Looks like we're
doing pretty good,
but we don't even know
how far left you can go.
So a pretty neat question.
And that is Mozart Kugel.
Any questions?
Other than, can I have some?
AUDIENCE: Where can we get some?
PROFESSOR: Where
can you get some.
That's a good question.
Most European airports
sell Mirabell.
So if you're flying through
Europe, it's the place to go.
Does anyone know if you
can get them locally?
I think maybe.
AUDIENCE: I think Cardullo's.
PROFESSOR: Cardullo's
that's a good place.
In Harvard Square.
They have a lot of
imported chocolates.
So, yeah, I think
they have Mirabell.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
There's a lot of imported
chocolates and confectioneries
in the Pru.
PROFESSOR: In the
Prudential Center.
All right.
These I think you have
to go to Salzburg.
Even in Austria
they're hard to get.
So these are very special.
I'll give Marty my second one.
All right.
That's all for today.
Hey, there's one thing I forgot
to talk about in lecture which
I think is really
cool so I'm going
to add a little bit to
what we were talking about.
We have all these
wrappings of the sphere
but I never proved to that
they're actually contractive.
How do you prove that all those
wrappings are contractive?
Well, there's a cool theorem we
proved just for this purpose.
I'll call it the Cauchy Arm
Lemma on a growing sphere.
It's a nice little connection
to Cauchy's Arm Lemma
which we talked about in the
context of Cauchy's rigidity
theorem for polyhedral.
Now, remember,
Cauchy's Arm Lemma
is about you have
some convex chain--
and actually it applies both
on the plane and the sphere.
So we're thinking
of an open chain
but we had the property that
even if you add the closing
edge it's convex.
And then we looked at
a flex of the chain
where all of the
angles increased
and we said, if all
the angles increase,
then this distance
increases, the endpoint--
the distance between
the endpoints increases.
That's regular
Cauchy's Arm Lemma.
But now I want to look at
not growing the angles,
but growing the sphere
that the linkage lives on.
So think of this in
the spherical case,
which we'll-- imagine this
thing is on a sphere and now I
transform it by taking a
larger sphere, larger radius,
and drawing exactly the same
edge lengths and angles.
Here, I'll draw it
a little bit curved
because in reality these
edges are great circular arcs.
So this edge length here
matches this length,
this angle matches this
angle, this edge length
matches this edge
length, and so on.
But I draw it on
a bigger sphere.
This theorem says, that the
distance between the endpoints
will increase also in that case.
So that's kind of neat.
And in the limit, if you take a
ginormous sphere, all the way--
if you take a really, really
big sphere, it becomes a plane.
So if I take
something on a sphere
and then I actually draw it on
the plane with the same angle--
so this planar angle
matches this spherical angle
and this length matches this
spherical length-- then,
in particular, this
distance will increase.
And in the reverse, if I
take a planar convex chain
and I redraw it on some
sphere, the distance
will go down provided
this thing is also convex.
So that's the Lemma.
Now, let me show you
how to use that to prove
that all those wrappings
are contractive.
It's really easy once
you have this Lemma.
Let's start with
the source wrapping.
So remember, we had a
sphere, the north pole,
and we took all these shortest
paths from the north pole
to the south pole.
All of those lines-- I want
to claim that-- and when
you unfold this you get a really
big disk and all those lines
become straight.
So what I need to show is that
between every pair of points,
the distance decreases when
I go from flat to sphere.
Which is exactly what
happened over here.
I went from flat to the sphere,
this distance decreased.
So that's how it's
going to be useful.
If I take two points, like,
say, this point and this point.
Any two points.
They live on one of these
spokes that goes to the center.
So draw those two
segments to the center
which was the north pole here.
So if I take the corresponding
two points up here,
I'm looking at that
path and that path.
Well, that's a convex chain
and the distance between them--
between those two points that
I started with, say, x and y,
is exactly the closing
distance of that convex chain.
So here's a convex chain,
it matches the angles
and the lengths of this
convex chain and the plane.
Therefore, this distance is
larger than this distance.
And so this is a
contractive map because it
works for any two
points x and y.
So that's the source wrapping.
With slightly more effort,
slightly more interesting
example, is the petal wrappings.
So think about one petal.
So let's say I just take-- in
fact, just think about half
of a petal.
So we had a petal look
something like that
going to the south pole here.
And so we bisected this thing
and then we took lots of ribs
like that.
So that's one half petal.
So when you unfold,
it looks like this.
Take any two points
on the half petal.
I'll show, first of all, that
the half petal is contractive.
So I take two points, say,
this one and this one,
call them x and y.
Now I take this rib,
this rib and this rib.
Those are the
stretched paths again.
They map to whatever up here.
Again, it's a
convex chain and so
this distance increases
when you go to the sphere
because it's convex
in both scenarios.
So that's half petals.
Now, when you worry
about a full petal
and you want to show the
whole wrapping is expansive,
you actually use a
different method.
So let's say we take
a whole petal here.
And I want to show not
only any pair of points
within a single half petal
contract but, in fact,
any two vertices, any
two points contract.
So I'm going to take x
and some other point.
Now I'll call it z.
If I did the-- just looked
at the stretched paths,
that's no longer convex.
I can't use the same trick.
But here's a new trick.
I take a straight line, a
shortest path from x to z,
which gives me a new
point y in the middle.
Now I know that this
distance contracts
because that's within
a single half petal.
So by the previous
argument, and by looking
at that little chain, I
know by this Arm Lemma
that distance contracts, I know
that this distance contracts.
So what about the
whole distance?
Well, if I look at the
distance from x to z--
that's what I care about--
let's say, in the plane,
this equals the sum
of those distances.
Because we drew a
straight line, it
equals the distance from x to y
plus the distance from y to z.
Now, I mapped these
onto the sphere,
call that d prime is
the spherical distance.
I know that when I look
at d prime I contract.
So d prime of xy is going
to be smaller for xy,
it's going to be smaller for yz.
What I really care
about is the distance
of the sphere between x and z.
But this is the
triangle inequality.
If you have a triangle xyz,
the distance from x to z
is always, at most,
the distance from x
to y plus the
distance from y to z.
That holds in any metric space.
So, in particular, it
holds on the sphere.
So this is sort of trivial.
This is triangle inequality.
And this was the contractiveness
that we already prove.
And this is just equal.
And so we get that
the new distance
is a contraction of
the old distance.
So that works on a full petal.
It actually-- this
exact same technique
works if you have a
full petal unfolding.
Maybe you have
something like this.
And you take-- finish it off--
you take two points anywhere
on any two petals,
like here and here, you
take the shortest
path between them
and again, you
could argue, well,
this is going to contract
because it is in a single half
petal, this is going to
contract because it's
in a single have petal.
Therefore, that sum
will also contract
by exactly the same argument.
And you can use that for
the comb wrapping too.
This is kind of neat
with this little Lemma
about growing spheres and
showing the distances increase,
you get to prove that all of
these wrappings are contractive
and therefore all these
things I was claiming
were working really do work.
You can formalize that
in a simple little way.